salud en directo América de France 24
Marina sardina está con nosotros en el
estudio Marina bienvenida buena mañana
de jueves y vamos a iniciar hablando del
informe publicado por unicef y la
agencia de la ONU para la infancia
también la Organización Mundial de la
Salud que revela que un niño joven murió
cada 4.4 segundos esto en el año 2021
Así es Raúl buenos días y hablamos de
muertes que son prevenibles evitables y
tratables y de ahí radica pues la
preocupación de unicef y de los
organismos sanitarios veamos unos mapas
sobre el panorama global de estos datos
desde 1990 si bien casi todo en casi
todo el mundo un recién nacido hoy en
día tiene más posibilidades de
sobrevivir que en 1990 sólo en 2021 más
de 5 millones de niños y niñas menores
de 5 años fallecieron y esto tiene mucho
que ver con las desigualdades sociales y
económicas en los contextos en los que
nacen estos niños y niñas en África
subsahariana están sujetos al mayor
riesgo de muerte infantil en el mundo
que esta tendencia sea ralentizado en
los últimos 30 años como vemos por
ejemplo en Nigeria que en 1990 tenía
unas casas de
331,6 decesos por cada mil nacidos este
el año pasado en 2021 esta tasa es de
115,2 también lo mismo ocurre con la
edad de supervivencia de los neonatos en
2021 fallecieron 2,3 millones de recién
nacidos un recién nacido en África
subsahariana tiene 11 veces más
posibilidades de morir que en el primer
mes de vida que un niño nacido en la
región de Australia o Nueva Zelanda el
riesgo de muerte en el primer mes de
vida de un niño nacido en un país de
ingresos altos era una décima parte del
riesgo de un niño nacido en países de
bajos ingresos también aquí una vez más
está denotando mucho pues la falta de
atención médica de las mujeres
embarazadas que van a dar a luz las
condiciones de higiene y salubridad
donde nacen estos niños la posibilidad
de tener controles Raúl de durante el
embarazo el acceso a tratamiento sin
medicamentos cuando nace el bebé si por
ejemplo tiene alguna anomalía también el
acceso al leche en polvo suplementos
nutricionales cuando la madre lactante
no puede dar el pecho y esto es crucial
para la supervivencia de estos recién
nacidos también para los menores que
sobreviven Más allá de los 28 Días la
enfermedad las enfermedades infecciosas
como neumonía malaria diarrea presentan
una amenaza mayor y si bien a nivel
Global en todas las regiones las
probabilidades de morir entre los cinco
y los 24 años es menor que la de los
menores de 5 años solo en 2021
fallecieron 2,1 millones de niños entre
los cinco y veinticuatro años el 43%
eran adolescentes Además este informe de
unicef reveló que uno coma nueve
millones de bebés nacieron muertos
durante ese mismo periodo de tiempo algo
que se podía haber evitado con un acceso
equitativo de la salud maternal
Marina unos datos realmente preocupantes
y un recordatorio que urge la necesidad
de poner fin a estas muertes No sí Y es
que también según unicef y la OMS
preocupa las grandes lagunas en datos
que podrían socavar el impacto de las
políticas diseñadas para mejorar la
supervivencia infantil y con la pandemia
de Kobe 19 esto queda un poquito
relegado un segundo plano y que no se
están haciendo unos monitoreos
exhaustivos teniendo en cuenta las
cifras que existen los mismos organismos
señala que se necesita reforzar los
sistemas de atención primaria en los
países del sur global que dependen
muchas veces de la atención de las
ayudas humanitaria y la cooperación
internacional y no de la del propio
estado Esto es lo que dice el informe
es sumamente Injusto que las
posibilidades de supervivencia de un
niño puedan depender únicamente de su
lugar de nacimiento y que existan
desigualdades tan grandes en su acceso a
los servicios de salud que salvan vidas
los niños de todo el mundo necesitan
sistemas sólidos de atención Primaria
para la salud que satisfagan sus
necesidades y las de sus familias para
que sin importar dónde nazcan tengan
mejor conocimiento y Esperanza para el
futuro Marina cambiamos ahora de tema
nos vamos a hablar de una situación que
está escalando a nivel global y son los
brotes de cólera algo de que lo que ya
estuvimos hablando a finales del año
pasado así Raúl nos acompañará más
Romero y también terminó el año hablando
del cólera en Haití por ejemplo y ya la
entrada de que están habiendo unos
rebrotes y unos casos de colar
alarmantes y es también una de las
consecuencias de la crisis climáticas
que golpean a los países pues más
empobrecidos una vez más y también los
conflictos en nuestros países magnifican
la situación de los brotes de cólera en
estos países sólo en 2022 la OMS
registró 31 países con de cólera en la
región de las Américas Haití es el país
más golpeado con
452 muertes solo desde octubre desde
inicio de octubre que fue cuando se
reportó el caso el primer caso aunque se
cree que hay un subregistro una vez más
precisamente por la falta de acceso a
este país para contabilizar precisamente
también la situación socioeconómica de
seguridad Pues agrava esta situación
pero los médicos del terreno señalan que
no creen que se convierta en una
epidemia como pasó en 2010 que en solo
10 años causó más de 10.000 muertos Esto
es lo que dijo la OMS sobre estos brotes
de cólera actuales
desde enero del año pasado 31 países han
notificado brotes un 50% más que en los
años precedentes los brotes en Sí están
más extendidos y son más mortíferos de
lo normal
en las últimas semanas cuatro países más
han solicitado vacunas que son
extremadamente escasas con el aumento
del número de brotes que son más grandes
geográficamente y el número hacemos un
llamamiento a los países que han
experimentado brotes de cólera con
anterioridad para que aumenten la
preparación ante posibles brotes piernas
por potencial out breaks precisamente
Raúl como señala la OMS hay una gran
escasez de vacunas Esta es una
problemática que tiene que ser abordada
con mayor investigación y mayor
desarrollo de vacunas para la
accesibilidad global Así es Marina
Muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información de salud mañana con más
mañana más y pasamos a saludar a